- (laughing) On the internet, sure.
Hi, I'm Henry Cavill,
and I'm here at BuzzFeed
to read some thirst tweets, here goes.
"Henry Cavill, I love you
with your glowing skin
"and your perfect face and the
beautiful curls in your hair,
"I just want to hug you
"because you are the love of my life."
Ooh, not nearly as thirsty
as I thought it might be,
I've read worse things in my comments.
United TOPS of Smash Bros (laughing)
"Henry Cavill can like, stick his tongue
"down my throat, I guess."
Thanks, thanks for the opportunity.
That definitely got thirstier.
"Henry Cavill could
destroy my body and my life
"and all I'd say is so does
tomorrow work for you too?"
Yes Sam, tomorrow does work for me too.
"Can I just say it Henry Cavill can
"destroy me like legit he
can superman this hoe."
That's very kind of you,
I appreciate your vigor.
But um, don't hurt yourself,
be careful out there.
"I would let Henry Cavill split me in half
"I'm just gonna say it."
Thanks for saying it.
What do people get up
to in their free time?
"Henry Cavill could
leave me on read at 4:30,
"text back at 8:47,
and I'd reply at 8:46."
That's a neat trick.
I really do need to get Twitter,
could spend hours reading this stuff.
Okay, this is the last one.
"Henry Cavill definitely
exudes Big Dick Energy,
"and to make it even better,
I'm 99% sure he's actually big,
"I'm weak just thinking about it."
Thank you.
Why the 1%, I ask?
And, furthermore, no comment.
See you BuzzFeed,
thank you very much for
your thirsty tweets,
very, very entertaining,
and complimentary.
And I'm probably getting
Twitter now, thanks.